هل تظل محتواة في أيدي الإسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين ، أنا فقط أتساءل عن
مدى أولوية هذا بالنسبة
للعرب الآخرين في المنطقة ، أعني أننا
رأينا بالفعل احتجاجات تظهر الآن
في الأردن
اتفاقيات التطبيع بين
إسرائيل ودول الشرق الأوسط الأخرى
، الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
السودان ، على سبيل المثال ، كيف يلعب هذا الأمر
في ذلك
إذا كان هناك سؤالان مختلفان على الإطلاق أعتقد أنهما يمثلان
أولوية
للعرب في المنطقة وسترى
مظاهرات واحتجاجات
على  لكن هذا لا يعني
أنه أولوية
بالنسبة لحكومات المنطقة فهو
ليس
أه تعلم رغم حقيقة أه إن
الإيرانيين انخرطوا في
دعم كبير لمنظمات
مثل حماس
السعودية وإيران الآن منخرطون
بشكل مباشر  أحاديث
لمحاولة التوسط في نوع من التقارب
بينهم أه الإمارات
بالتأكيد أدانت العنف
وطلبوا من الإسرائيليين عدم
وهبط
لكن هذا لم يهدد بأي حال من
الأحوال اتفاق إبراهيم
على أن توسطًا دبلوماسيًا مباشرًا
هو خلق علاقات بين
إسرائيل والإمارات العربية المتحدة
وإسرائيل والبحرين وتوثيق العلاقات
مع السعوديين ،
كل هذه الأمور صحيحة وكذلك بالنسبة
للإمارات العربية المتحدة.  إدارة بيدن أقول إن
الأولوية
لإسرائيل
وفلسطين هي بالطبع عندما كان بايدن نائباً للرئيس ثم
وزير الخارجية كيري عامه الأول
ونصف
إسرائيل كانت الأولوية القصوى
لأه وزير الخارجية أم
عندما كان بايدن نائباً  الرئيس ، إنه
ليس قريبًا من ذلك في الوقت الحالي ،
إنه ليس للأمريكيين أم إنه ليس
أه بالنسبة لمعظم البلدان في
الشرق الأوسط وهذا بالطبع يضع
الفلسطينيين في موقف أكثر صعوبة بشكل كبير